I want you to see if you can unpack this
phrasing for me to try to work out what
it means before we even look at what the
textbook says we just described what a
sample was right so we know what tables
are it's like a little cross-section of
the population so what do you think the
sample means is what this table may
represent okay very good so it's like
here's this set all of the actual and I
average them out according to say height
for example okay so I can look at the
mean of my tables right that's fair
enough
why is it clearly mine is plural
several means not simple being okay I
can take like look here's one example of
sample but if I do this again or if I
don't ask every twenty person I ask
every 19th person I'll get a whole
different simple and the whole point of
a samples just like the cross-section in
our president is in this one but I could
have easily think of this one or that
one or there's a whole bunch of
different ones okay so in a population
there are multiple sample means in fact
can we just write that down in a
population there are multiple of these
right is lots of slots therefore there's
lots of different ones that's the whole
point of a table so if you've got a
whole machine for examples and everyone
you can work out a mean what does this
mean we looked at this word under our
last data statistics subunit what did
the word distribution yeah okay so the
whole idea is the means are will be
different there will be different so how
are they spread out where are they how
can we we work out a pattern right so
this is how are the meetings spread out
that's literally what does should be to
be okay so she's the example that I want
to think about
eg okay so if you had some dice strength
and I gave you all one and I said okay
we're going to roll it twice okay we're
gonna do a lots and lots and lots of
times every time we roll it twice we get
a new sample in a new symbol and then we
can work out the mean of that set so I
want to try and work out what's the
distribution of those means the first
thing we need to do just like that I
went through the words is you've got to
work out what are the samples if you've
got two diets how many different ways
are there to actually get a different
combination okay so I wanted to imagine
let's do this without repetition we'll
come back to this frame in a minute how
we would do differently if it was with
repetition so let's suppose we can't
pick the same number twice I'm going to
pause remove it I don't want to ask you
to try and work out how many different
combinations are there how many
different samples would there be so if
you roll the dice or or design and you
have two different numbers out I'll give
you any clocking one of them six comma
five that is a sample that's one of the
possible bid you could get as you roll
them let me give you another one I'm
from before I just keep in you two these
are two of the samples and each of these
tables had a mean like you can work out
the mean of those or you can work out
the mean of those we'll get to those
people in to the second I can't really
work out how many samples are there that
are different in this population can you
spend two minutes trying to work that
out you can we get however way you like
you talk to a friend if you want see if
you can get them all down
off you go I've learn a lot of different
answers so I want to get something on
the board first before we discuss it
again
thirty I also have this day what all the
horses I've got a twelve
[Music]
about Honda's anything yep
66 zero used to provide my gosh yes this
variation that me might be contacted by
the time were you not in my me I'm not
you kind of secrecy
that's a repetition because it you know
whatever recalls yes any other
suggestions we've invested well okay all
right sure
let's bring this to go yeah he's the one
that a lot of wonderful things about
this problem when you get given another
I've told you this before right when you
arrive at an answer for a question
you're interfacing the context for
question is we need to go to the back of
the book but that then begs the question
well how did they know what the answer
was and as we've demonstrated or for
statistics local works which would
advise you with the use as well okay so
how can we sort out which one of these
it is okay now I noticed what I looked
around and I didn't see many how I
started writing out answers I started
writing about there's nothing stopping
you to writing out the others right and
you can actually started it
I mean your numbers are large but
they're not ridiculous right so I can
actually start to try and form something
of a systematic leads to you right so
that's what I'm going to try and do and
then let's see if we can observe that 6
& 5 6 & 5 I will do this in a systematic
way not a random way because I want to
make sure I get everything okay so I'm
just excited I'm actually going to go
six and four that's also possibility
isn't it and I want to be trying to
listening so I'm going to go to 6 & 4 6
3 6 & 2 & 6 & 1
did I get the ball is right there right
so these are all possible samples from
my population hold double Dykstra
okay now you'll notice this one here I
started spiteful I have included five
five what was that for one - okay I'm
not including repetition I had included
five six either why not
okay now they're being quizzes and the
second is a different honor you need to
close yourself the question because you
all have enough knowledge to work out
why five six is not in this list we'll
try to work out we're trying to work out
like this is not just a tional literal
samples and we're trying to work out the
sample means corrected now think about
this and think that this is the same
sample or only different ones it's the
same because it's the same numbers not
less different order so if I said if I
said okay I'm going to take a sample a
sample right on this school and I'm
going to compose that sample all Java
g22 I just decided to ever do it does
the sample change if you walked in in
alphabetical order or if you walk it
hype order or if you walked in here that
you don't reverse alphabetical or
anything like that one so are you saying
yeah we took out a blue marker
yep then we put
great animated that's what yes more or
less commitment-phobic Alexis porches
let me help you recognize these are the
same samples these these are identical
samples it's the same role the same
people if you like they are in there
like imagining my hair instead alone
it's all stay with me this is a tricky
idea so I might want to make sure
they're missing paintings of you have
all the pieces if these six numbers were
actually people so I took the six equals
a front row and which person I end up
putting an example is just defined by
their number right
if remain in the six injections of five
they're rolling six and five is the same
as rolling five inches into ten when I
work out the difference a people and
they're going to have the same safe will
make you look great okay so this is why
I have not include I skipped five six I
skip by five
I got five for one minute three and then
there's what do you think moving action
complicated right now I can keep going
and doing this right in fact you'll see
a patent the next one I have to skip 4 6
y by and skipping for six separate
because I already have it right I'm
going to get four five as well why
because I already have it I'm using four
four because so I'm going to start there
yeah so where is my patent leave me
what do you think are you satisfied
why do my rows start six five four three
two what happened one well-known only
one you can't have one one right but
then when you think about all the rest
of them I actually do have the roadside
in big ones do you notice it you see
where it is sana diagonal just over job
so you see because I did this finishes
to make where I have it all there I
can't come on cut him up okay now what's
really interesting is yes that's
corrected Johnson this is not the only
way to do because obviously this thing
is okay in this case 15 was not too hard
but if I gave you not like a design with
six sides but as dine with 65 which is
not that crazy like a group of 60 people
I thought that difficult to imagine
right you don't want to do this soon
again you don't do this so how we go
about this in a more systematic way so
just besides everything empty okay I
want you to draw out one of these do you
remember these if we list each of these
or I need another one
total area so let's just remove it if I
this oughta be done right they did like
the first role there are six
possibilities okay I think you have to
roll again now we're going to draw the
entire being actually my Catholic come
on you get a six of them in a 16-bit
right but I'm going to stop you can
actually have six why not think is that
repetition is repetition could so how do
I adjust it to make it a little bit
better make it five minutes a side right
now see look I'm not even draw the red
you've got enough to see a pattern here
there are six branches here every single
one of the next level is going to have
five so how many little branches all I
have at the end it'll be six and each
one in a group of five so that's six
times five which is they hold on a
second 30 was one of the answer
help you but it's clearly not that I
wasn't here what's wrong what's the
relationship between turn into two
subgroups half what is half the other
why is the correct answer exactly half
of what we get out of this particular
slot daughters of the externalities so
one of the options here is 1/6
right and then one of the options here
will be 6 1 which we decided was the
same sample right so exactly half of
these will be the other ones in reverse
order
do you agree so you should divide by 2
which gives you 50 the directors